hey guys first of all thank you for
clicking you're about to watch a new
video or another video on YouTube and
before you do - 1 2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 what
I'm doing in my text community is
bonkers it's instant it's access it's
exclusive and now enjoy this YouTube
video almost everybody is watching this
blog it's spending an hour on dumb [ __ ]
that's actually a 12-minute meeting
don't make 12 minute meetings 1 hour
meetings
nonsense you got your prospectus
[Music]
for me what I've done for the last you
know 12 years so for sure is continue to
beat a drum publicly about where are the
opportunities to garner organic reach
that quote unquote you don't deserve
meaning I the people listening right now
you start a tick tock account you post
something and 200,000 people watch it I
do rock it was this morning rights and
on just posted something in our thread
I think somebody left a comment saying
their first video I'm ticked I've got
400,000 views
that's what early Twitter did that's
what early Facebook did
that's what early YouTube did most of
the people right now know that you don't
post a youtube you don't tweet a tweet
you don't post a Facebook post and
magically all these people see it in
fact including Instagram almost nobody
sees it there are always times where
organic reach is popping on a platform
because there's more attention on the
platform than there is content filling
that attention currently the two places
that that's happening are tick tock and
LinkedIn so obviously for a lot of
people listening and watching LinkedIn
is gonna make more sense
the reason tik-tok has you know it's
funny I'm saying both of them pretty
equally it's that tick tock for most
humans when they hear that is the place
where their eleven-year-old daughter or
niece is on so they find it funny
it seems weirder you should have seen
the backlash or not the my gosh
the pushback I got when I was yelling
about Facebook in 2010 11 12 people
still consider that a college social
network so yeah I want to be
historically correct I want to bring the
most value as an entrepreneur to
entrepreneurs and the way I know how to
do that is to for free put out content
that inspires and gives insights to
places where there's opportunity tick
tops single most important thing for
everybody's listening is the following
if it goes older
if it adds photos instead of just these
videos if it involves no different than
the way Instagram about Instagram how to
add stories to stop a fast-moving
snapchat that was gaining market share
if they evolve and if the demo gets
older I do believe it becomes a very
important place for people in 24 and 36
months trying to sell real estate
sneakers courses clothes you know
whatever and so but if it doesn't and
this is the most important part if it
doesn't it already has hundreds of
millions of people reacting to it so
some of the behaviors on it inevitably
will be things that we as creators and
communicators
need to add to our repertoire whether
that happens on Instagram because of a
feature change or lipstick comes out and
becomes the next thing with 30% nuances
of tick-tock I became a great creator
because I was on social cam I was on
vine I was on Peach
I was on all these things that did not
go on to win even but I was learning and
by the way when I was on vine I got
value out of that right now um I've got
I built a huge audience I picked up I've
had more people stopped me under-15
saying hey you're the tic-tock guy in
the last month that means I know that
that means that it's working and once
you get the attention you're building
brand and if tick tock disappears
tomorrow and I go take those 16 year old
fans and we are interacting on YouTube
podcast and my text platform 2 1 2 9 3 1
5 7 3 1 for everybody who's listening
once you have the attention you get the
siphon it I will leave you with this and
this is a long-winded answer when when
Seinfeld's the number one show on TV you
run commercials on it nobody cries when
Seinfeld then stops airing that brand
goes and runs commercials on Empire or
the the masked singer whatever you know
I don't know why people are so obsessed
with a social media platform sticking
around forever I don't hear if any of
them stick around forever I care about
when the attentions on them am I the
best executor of content
on it to siphon brand and awareness to
keep moving the screen along we're in
Denver Colorado now to speak to a an
entire roomful of executives from
fast-casual q sr the food industry the
emerges and the establishment great
space for me a lot of my belief of
communication is affecting the
restaurant industry they the fast food
places the sit down places like just
really affecting and so I have a lot of
points of view on how they're
communicating from the marketing
standpoint way to traditional there's so
much opportunity and so I'm excited
about this talk quite a bit
[Music]
I come to every speech the same way
which is I'm so flattered to be there
I'm so humbled to be compensated the way
I am I'm desperate to bring the most
value and the way that I know how to do
that is to put the truths that are
actually happening in the system and are
obvious to me on a plate in front of the
audience I know that 95 percent of the
people do nothing about it but I am
telling you right now for the five
percent here that will consider it
here's the formula here's the
prescription you have to become some you
you have to become somebody that knows
how to run ads and makes pictures videos
and audio on these ten social networks
from LinkedIn Facebook Twitter YouTube
you you have to understand it cold
you cannot outsource this because how
will you hire people or hire partners to
do it if you don't know how to judge it
and so all that effort into figuring out
the perfect location because of traffic
and all that arbitrage or the
decorations of within or all those
things they still matter but every
second that goes by they matter less and
the ability to know how to run an
Instagram swipe up ad for $3 CPMs within
a four-mile radius of your store against
44 different pieces of creative to make
all those citizens feel contextual to
then convert into traffic and hire
receipt spend that matters more and will
continue to if you don't have a
tick-tock and LinkedIn strategy for your
restaurants right now you're making a
mistake because they're the two places
that have the most organic reach where
you don't even have to pay for media to
build awareness both seem wildly crazy
for this sector based on what they are
LinkedIn has historically been a B to be
recruiting place which has now become
really Facebook 2012 and tik-tok
everybody thinks it's just for 11 year
olds just like we used to think Facebook
was only for college kids don't even get
me started on the fact that the 12 to 14
year old girl in a family usually
influences the mom's buying decisions
and she's the one that actually buys for
the whole household please let's get
more thoughtful please understand where
this is going if you have not committed
to truly acting like a media
company producing continent scale your
competitor will you think people got it
I think so yeah it's very much B to B to
C yeah just curious more on the b2b
LinkedIn yeah giving them content that
actually brings them value not awareness
for your business which that leads to
awareness of your business
got it got it b2b companies crush on
LinkedIn if they actually give if you do
five tips for a restaurant to win on a
link on Instagram as your post on
LinkedIn right they'll be like who is
this guy and I'm like Oh Bobby see what
I mean what about the quality of the
content that's a turd subjective okay
lighting audio it's all subjective I
know the [ __ ] big Star Wars how is
that everyone with the legend himself
Gary Vee what's up YouTube how we doing
okay hey brother how do you make dreams
come true two ways one actually having
them and to not being crippled by having
them and executing on a daily basis if
you can't pull from both sides you're
finished so first we have to have it
there has to be a North Star but where
people get hurt is every day they're
wondering why they haven't reached it so
I have great ambitions and dreams but I
don't think about them daily I know they
exist but daily I just execute daily I
execute and then I wake up in 50 years
and see where I'm at thank you you got
it yeah take care
hi thank you for shaking your head in
the front I saw you and I was like the
positive reinforcement it was I mean I
was just soaking in everything you're
saying I listen to you every day oh
thank you yes I mean
right now and I'm usually a really
confident don't worry what what are some
things you do oh that I put my number
and then love it the question I was
gonna ask but you know what are some
things that you do every day that you
think are habitual consistent things
that help you make good decisions I keep
things in perspective extremely well
both time and how important businesses
in comparison in real life which is it's
not all of a sudden when you know you
have a lot of time and you don't think
things are that serious
you're dramatically happier yeah almost
everybody's upset because they don't
think they have time and they think
everything's super serious every day I
put those two things in perspective
which makes everything else pop and
almost like done is better than perfect
I don't even
I hate perfect I think perfect is the
worst perfect is based on insecurity
right perfection for alysus is the worst
it's insecurity you don't you're scared
of other people's feedback on it so you
are aiming for some theoretical
perfection I don't care what they think
duck there is no perfect that's the
liberating it's the liberating King Wow
yeah
heading to LA now as you guys know I
don't like to get bougie and go private
but we got to get to LA because we got a
speech there too and then I got to do
Michael bad Julie's podcast kicker for
the Chargers being a sports guy so I'll
be in the office just living the dream
give up just did a bunch of one of the
fun thing one of the things that people
don't do is they don't max time you know
I basically have done seven or eight
phone calls already today that I
genuinely believe most executives spend
their 9:00 to 6:00 in the office doing
one hour meetings when they're actually
13 minute calls forty minute calls so
one of you know obviously sometimes I
extreme travel yet I still have to run a
third thousand person agency and I'm an
operator so I've had seven client calls
putting out a fire doing a strategy road
map I've had four or five executive
calls d-roc and I I don't think we
caught it but I got in the car right off
the stage he's like he got a call he
kind of laughed I'm like it looks good
on paper I was talking about like just
it's so intense but like every minute
like I just got off the phone when a
client now we're just getting on I will
now answer emails until I land
it's maximizing time people like how do
you handle it all
like huh it's by actually being good at
like you've got to be good at time
management
you've got to realize almost everybody's
watching this blog it's spending an hour
on dumb [ __ ] that's actually a 12-minute
meeting don't make 12 minute meetings 1
hour meetings nonsense
what and your code and I'm posting
content and I'm thinking LM watching a
[ __ ] out here do it how are you
[Music]
yep okay I'll let you go see ya
and on the last night name
right what a great point like literally
everything that I was just talking about
the rock to your point of like milk
every second like
if I wasn't willing to do the last two
posts which both underperformed by my
core metrics on Instagram I also might
have not been able to get to the piece
of content that is the new foundation of
my best organic reach we are driven by
fear in many places and definitely in
content creation in the current platform
that matters most of you are fearful on
your content on Instagram I hope this
series of three posts changes mine
[Music]
thanks madam get excited to get out
there take care hey pearl
real pleasure how are you dude I'm so
incredibly happy to see you thank you
very much looking forward to seeing you
out there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you guys for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
badge baby kissing love we've been
frustrated I know you've never missed
any [ __ ] football in your life my
talent is people right my talents people
and so I understand it sometimes
intuitively about a human like I do a
badge
other times it's about trends I'll give
you a good one I
I knew that online dating in the early
2000s
would eventually not have stigma oh I
got a good one let me go wild on you on
the way driving here talking to Tyler
and d-roc I'm like yo I might get the
LeBron hair implants I'm losing my hair
I'm 43 I'm like [ __ ] it I might get hair
implants and they're like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about like bro I'm
telling you this is like online dating
right now there's a stigma but I know
you 30 year old [ __ ] in 25 years are
gonna do it it's gonna be normal
why not kill Brady well yeah okay sorry
AJ this is what I'm visit how I'm like
making up for all the Patriot fans that
are mad at me like like the bottom line
is like it's about understanding what
humans are gonna do when they say
they're not gonna do it people used to
[ __ ] on online dating now people spend
24 hours/day slipping into DMS right
like people like people said they would
never have you know again you guys are
youngsters but the people listening a
little bit older nobody believed in the
you can't believe how many people did
not believe in the iPhone cuz the
BlackBerry you could feel the buttons
that's what everybody said like people
said they would never go on Facebook
because it was college and now every 40
to 90 year-old lives on Facebook and all
the young people left right now people
are saying they're not can be on tik-tok
because they're 11 year-old niece or
sister or on it and they can't see
themselves on it I'm really good at
saying they're gonna say no now but
eventually they're gonna fold I remember
a lot of people disagreed with me that
Facebook would get older and the single
reason I knew it was gonna work was when
Facebook was growing I started seeing
people that grad that joined Facebook at
22 when they were seniors in college now
Facebook was in year five and they were
27 and they had a child and I noticed
they were putting all their photos just
on Facebook and I remember I used to
call it remember age I used to call it
the grandmother rule I was like if
they're gonna put their photos on
Facebook
every one of these [ __ ] mothers is
gonna sign up because they want to see
little picture of little [ __ ] Michael
you know and so like and so I knew that
was going to work and so that's what I
look for like it all it takes is one
thing
[Music]
[Music]